hello and welcome to a small clip from
our weekly game of thrones show gamespot
of Thrones for the whole episode make
sure to head over to youtube com /
gamespot and we'll see you there I estoy
Don has been kind of like one of my
favorites this series just it keeps it
goes just like every episode like
something great in happens and I'm
really enjoying where it's going Dave's
just throwing me this absolute curveball
of a fan theory that I am I love Dave
take away so there was a hint at a game
ball hmm at this episode Jamie Jamie
mentions the trial by combat including
at the mountain and we've always thought
that the trial by combat would be the
mountain versus the hound but there was
a slight variant on that theory that I
found on the reddit by a redditor named
salted pork delicious excellent name and
in their post they say I'm pretty sure
we'll see Arya Stark as sandicor gained
versus Gregor Clegane in the game ball
2016 so I guess the theory is that now
she's no one she will take the face off
the hound mm-hmm then fight the mountain
but if you think about it like that be
hell of a fight like the mountains
weakness with the one fight we've seen
him almost lose ya was against the Viper
and that was because he couldn't keep up
with the Vipers speed if I was waiting
fast also he's wearing like loads of
heavy hot arman in like 30 degrees sun
yeah which he now can no longer take off
and like I said his weakness was
fighting against someone who's very fast
area pretty damn speedy he is nifty
husband Dexter ease up til oh yeah max
level decks like we've seen her fight
with needle in the past we've seen her
most recently fighting with the staff
Mike and she small so she'd get around
that but do we think this theory could
happen I mean it's not it's not actually
mentioned if the faceless men can change
size as well i was gonna say cuz like an
ayah size tiny mouths hanging around
toppy all of its ok would it work as a
thing if we find out that the faceless
man could also change size are you some
sort of glamour to do that as well hmm
here we could hold water but I think I
think that's the main thing that could
hello all apart I was gonna say the
travel time
I mean we've already seen travel time
isn't really too important because we've
seen people zip from the wall to the
plague island and it's a line and
Stannis and Davis went two Bravo yeah
yeah but are you at the moment is in
Braavos and I don't know how long it
takes to get from there to King's
Landing but she's not even considering
that at the moment so we'd have to see
some pretty fast development for her to
go from I'm learning how to hit people
with a stick to I'm gonna dress up as
the guy I killed that one time and fight
I also think though the the gravedigger
theory at least at this point definite
holds more water yeah someone's seen
like someone who could be the hound but
also the hounds horse that's the thing
like if if like it's a big if if
faceless men can change size and if area
does turn into the Hound a disguise of
the hound then I mean they've people are
still seeing the hound hmm maybe someone
else could have been the hound yeah just
what kind of you two could just be a
mistake like I'm not sure this theories
gonna happen but my god is an
interesting one how did they get his
face they've got a lot faces yeah but
its journey do you got a face do you
have to cut it off well you've seen
jackin i think in one of the trailers
zzz maybe she did that off camera just
took it put it in a back yeah bird one
guy's face along buck and you're done
before yeah also else what's the next
episode called was that book of
strangers strangers one of the seven
gods yeah so that would kind of tie in
with the faith no he was the other half
of that trial by combat and also i might
be wrong here what's what's the hounds
horse called does i think i read it was
called stranger that could be wrong but
if that's right that's too quickly and
maybe you can read so it's got a book
that's stranger than area b of the
hounds
you